Well, the first one is in some sense the identity transformation.
We're not actually doing any work here.
For everything in 1, 2, 3, just put that in the output.
That will totally work.
Here we're going to take 0, 1, 2, but we're going to add 1 to each,
so 0 + 1 is 1, 1 + 1 is 2, 2 + 1 is 3.
That will give us the output we expect.
Here we're going to do the reverse and subtract.
This will be -1, 0, 1.
That's not what we were hoping for.
Here we're going to divide a bit. 3 divided by 2 is 1.5.
That's kind of close, but 6 divided by 2 is 3.
This is not getting us the answer we want in the right order.
And finally, over here, length of a is 1.
My is 2 and the is 3, so we get the answers we expect.
Here I've written those answers out explicitly in Python in the interpreter,
and we're just going to check and see that we got the answers that we expected.
1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3. That's good.
This was much too low.
Here the division didn't work out properly, but in the last one it worked out fine.
We could totally fix this last one.
If we divide by 3 instead, we will get 1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3, but it was off by 1.